holdin the rebound yes
Simmons against five Joey listen hand
off the four-minute work
with the terrific defense have Dudley
let slipper in the Simmons
he gives a lot of moves here's a 3-bike
doesn't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like the games disappear with telling
them what's up just mounted in yeah good
job
[Applause]
people
the town whistle
with the puss on right here's the three
by deadly and look at the reaction yeah
what's up what's that bin okay reddit
picks up his second personal foul but
five assists for deadly and offensive
not in nothing runs to the rain and the
biggest lead of 10 is now down
the shove after that playing nothing
called eight-point game
difference of five seconds game clock
and shot clock winding down the first
half hearing sold out Brooklyn with the
stitches up two games to one McGuirk
around the screen and the swipes and a
feed and buckle is there a draft Elise
Paul Butler
[Applause]
Brooklyn wits 4.9 watch the basket after
a Simmons makes the basket a little
shoving match here between Dudley and
Simmons no love loss here between Jared
Dudley and Ben Simmons Joe Harris will
leave I'll bring in signature and take
that side and be then crashing again to
the floor
goodness
Dudley and Simmons into the stands
[Applause]
have to go back a couple games
beep to an elbow is governor asked
take it back
elbow up on the chops to Ellen it was
another shot from envied Alan Dudley
didn't like it
and what made it worse was the postgame
press oh when Ben Simmons and Joelle
indeed was asked about that and they
were joking so here's the heart first
from NB
on Jared Allen I mean that's it that's
all ball doesn't even touch his head
but here's gently coming in in the
middle of it Butler pushes and then
Butler with the push in the back side
and then it extends into the front row
right in front of the Sixers bench
I mean that is a good hard foul by an
beat because it's gone for the ball it
looked bad in real time and then here
you see and then you got Simmons and
then B and there's no law of gloss
between those two and you got coach
Kinney Atkinson Harris Fred Galloway
team security